okay
now let's see are we live
do i see any
people there
um
hello nobody there
boy
okay well just in case anyone is still
there i want to apologize for the uh
technical problems this morning um
normally i would see if we have a number
of people watching i don't seem to see
anyone so here what happened was i
connected my ipad via quicktime player
to my uh
computer and i was going to show you
what i do
but that seemed to freeze
this google hangout in some way
and uh but if some people would ask a
question or comment just to let me know
if anyone is still out there
uh so
then i decided to relaunch my google
hangout meeting here
but it would simply not
come alive so there were lots of back
and forth and finally i created a new
broadcast uh so all of this took uh you
know five six seven minutes um
i don't know if i still have anyone
listening at this point i apologize
for the confusion
and he went out there
i don't know i'm not gonna talk
well i might still have a little
chat here because this will still go up
on uh
on youtube
for people to view later on so
the intention today was to show you
how i use my ipad to study
uh at link
and to do some studying with my ipad
but uh i wasn't i'm not i'm not gonna
attempt it now because i'm afraid it'll
shut things down so i'm gonna save that
for another occasion once i've worked
out all the technical glitches
so what i want to do today is to show
you uh some things that relate to
studying farsi but they're not limited
to studying farsi and they affect
basically
anything that that we want to do in the
language
so now i'm going to share my screen as
i've done in the past again i apologize
for the delay getting started
and uh you know
we got to learn these things there's a
lot of trial and error in all of this
stuff
uh so screen share
and we're going to go here
desktop too
start screen share so hopefully you're
looking at my
farsi page all right
now
the uh
the first thing that i'm going to do is
so
here we see
and so i was going to demonstrate what i
do with farsi
uh farsi is one of the languages for
which we don't have text-to-speech
now i just wanted to before going any
further talk a bit about text-to-speech
i do get some comments here from sort of
purists
saying the arabic text-to-speech
pronunciation is not good
please ignore it and stuff like that
uh
i find the text to speech very useful i
realize that it is not always accurate
in fact might often not be quite
accurate
given that i listened to the content the
natural voice
20 30 40 times 50 times in some cases
the
text-to-speech is not going to corrupt
my sense of accurate pronunciation
uh it's very useful to get a sense of a
new word of how it's pronounced even if
it's a little bit inaccurate
and this brings me to i think a very
important point in language training
which i cannot stress enough one little
incident one
text-to-speech pronunciation of a word
which is off one little error in a text
one mistake that you made
or make any little incident
is
not in is is relatively insignificant it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because
in the course of my learning arabic or
you're learning spanish or chinese
you should be exposed to so much content
that that one little grain of sand
that's out of place is not going to have
any major impact it's far more important
to charge ahead
exposing yourself to as much of a
language as possible some people will
have funny accents some people will use
the language in a strange way but it'll
all cancel itself out if you do enough
listening and reading so and and i
should point out too that
even when you have trouble speaking as i
had
i think i did better in my second
session in arabic than in the first it
doesn't matter because the learning we
do obviously we would like to do well we
always like would like to do well but
the main thing is to improve our
comprehension and i find now in farsi as
i'm able to go through these texts read
them and understand them i have a
tremendous sense of power a sense of
power that power that comes from feeling
that we are gaining on the language and
once i have a sufficient
level of comprehension that i can listen
to all kinds of interesting content
compelling content things of interest to
me
i will progress in the language and
eventually i will be able to speak well
and so
the amount of times that i fall flat on
my face
at an early or even intermediate stage
in the language or even subsequently
when i feel i already speak the language
well but still make mistakes
with some of the most basic issues in
the language none of this matters and
certainly the
slightly strange text-to-speech in
arabic doesn't matter okay i just wanted
to get that off my chest because the
number of comments along those lines uh
on my youtube channel so
with farsi i have my easy content like
who is she which is a little more
difficult than the many stories
uh i review my conversation reports
which is again very useful because this
is content that's a live for me because
it's stuff that i've tried to say
uh
my tutor rana has created an even easier
version of the many stories her mini
stories which i used at the beginning
are quite easy
uh
and i have persian online so i just
wanted to show you where persian online
comes from
because every language that i have
learned romanian
czech polish
if you look
enough
and maybe you have to look
in the language you can find
content online so persian online
is this tremendous
source
which has beginner lessons elementary
lessons and intermediate lessons
and and in the case let's let's take the
elementary which is where i'm spending
most of my time now
you know they have
uh
you know they have the text translation
glossary
dialog 1.2 so what i typically do is i
go into the persian text here
and then i highlight the whole text
and it's a little tricky doing it with
sort of arabic and farsi because it goes
from right to left
and then i copy that
and then i go to i'm not going to do it
the whole way through because i already
have it but i go then to my farsi i
click here
import the lesson
all right
and
i go to the course which in this case
would be persian online this was persian
online two
and i select that i paste the lesson
here i put a title up here
and then i also download there was an
audio file
i'll just let that
let that ring
that's the
problem of having the
ipad
so
gosh
[Music]
hello
goodbye okay
so here's the audio a lot of times with
the audio it's save link as enables you
to download the mp3 file
i have downloaded some as you can see in
the bottom of my screen here
this then when i am in my
uh wherever here
there you upload the audio file you
click on that it'll go to your desk to
my desktop or wherever i have that file
and so then i add the uh the audio and
then i have a lesson and if i wanted to
i could put you know the translation in
here
they have a glossary i could add that as
lesson notes uh so this is how i build
up
content once i am beyond
uh you know what's in our um
what's in our library at link
so if i go to my persian online two
which is sort of the intermediate
level persian online three is i've
already started some of them uh which
are really fun because they're talking
about iran they're talking about
persepolis they're talking about
famous figures from persian history and
so that's really interesting stuff more
difficult and so i kind of go back and
forth between the very easy and the uh
the less easy so
if i go here and open up persian online
too
so there's a lot of stuff here
uh i think i was doing this one here
just now
so
it's exciting to me
that i'm actually able to read this and
i listen to it i can make sense of most
of it
and earlier on i would mostly go in
sentence mode
but now i go in full text mode
and i've already been through on the
computer how i say phrases so i'm not
going to do that again
and or how i review links so none of
that is is i was hoping to do that on
the ipad to show you but
i can't so maybe before going any
further i should turn it over to you if
there's any particular questions you
have or things that you would like me to
review
uh you know obviously
i should point out that uh my tutor rana
here
so she's my tutor she's excellent uh boy
i haven't tried him at four bucks an
hour i might go and see if he's
available
uh
these are the two tutors we have i can
check my activities
here and i can see that that's you know
this is where i line up my tutors
and uh
but anyway
enough of that let's get back to my
lessons
and um
ask you if um
unless of course
pretty soon i'm going to be going into
the sort of news items that we scraped
uh but uh
but uh
yeah so let's go to uh go back to my
lessons
and um
questions so let us see here what have
we got let me open up slack
so people right now let's go to it over
here 90 day challenge
reading okay what is the next language
you're going to study after farsi in
arabic
uh probably turkish
and um
you know i'm at a stage where i can
study whatever i want
i don't write exams i do what interests
me
so i have
you know i had my sort of romance
language period i had my
asian language period i had my slavic
language period and right now in my mind
i'm exploring the world of the middle
east central asia
and there is
tremendous cultural
inter sort of connection between
arabic farsi and turkish
certainly there's
many there are many recognizable arabic
words in farsi i am told the same is
true in turkish
there are connections in terms of food
music history obviously the
religion um
and and there were many you know i mean
the persian empire included
arabic lands the arab you know islamic
world grew to include
uh turkey and
iran
the ottoman empire included turkish and
obviously turkish and then arabic and
farsi speaking people
and and so to me it's just
an interesting thing to explore so i'm
definitely going to go
to uh
to turkish next
the next question is how long you've
been studying arabic uh i would say a
little over a year but i mean in that
period i spent a month traveling in
latin america i spent a month traveling
i can't remember we were you know so
there's there's months of time in there
where i'm not
at the arabic
but
for a year it has been the language that
i'm working at on so when i have an
opportunity
um so you know it might average to an
hour or so a day and but it now that i'm
on the 90-day challenge it's more than
that
uh because i think i'm spending more
than two hours a day
except i'm spending the first three days
of the week with arabic and the second
three days of the week with farsi
and um yeah that's the answer to that
question
any other questions here before i
continue
no okay
so you know if i were on my own here uh
if like the ideas that we're studying
together i would open my persian online
except i would do it
i would do it on uh
on my ipad
uh
so i'm right now at lesson 30 here
or 31 rather practice so i would open up
that
i've listened to it i was listening to
and listening to it this morning as i
was uh making breakfast and there were
words in there that i wasn't totally
sure of
so i would go and uh
em ruse
chambe ast
saturday
man
uh
so
yeah i know all of those are fine i'm
doing fine we like saturdays
va
is a sports club
but i might want to say that all right
and so what i would do is simply
even though i've been through it once i
kind of understand it i go through it
again and try and
rework some of these words
bear in mind i think this is another
important point
you know we have a limited amount of
time to spend on the language
so
sometimes we're inclined to want to try
to nail down the vocabulary
no matter how much we nail it down we'll
forget it again
uh
so we have to be realistic about how
much nailing down we do
i'm not sure in my mind whether
by proceeding and doing more content i'm
because even in going to new content
you're seeing old
friends again
uh whether i'm better off to go forward
or whether i'm better off to try and
concentrate on a few words i tend to
feel that at the early stage
i tend to more want to nail things down
just so that i can
otherwise it's too difficult to read new
material
but eventually i kind of get more and
more extensive
as i go along i don't know what that was
okay a couple of questions here what was
the most difficult romance language for
you
[Music]
um
yeah
hard to say
uh
i would say obviously the first romance
language was french
and i spent more time on french than
any other
and
after that
it's kind of all the same uh i mean in a
way romanian should be the most
difficult because
it has
funny little
uh case endings
and it has 25 or 20 slavic words and 5
10
words that predate in other words from
the sort of call it dalmatian or or
whatever original romanian
but actually by that time i had done so
many romance languages that i found at
romanian quite easy
so i don't think there's any difference
uh what is the best approach for looking
at words i don't know when reading
should i skim the sentence first and
look up the words before i read and
listen or should i read and listen first
and then look up
very interesting question so i'm
assuming that
you're working on link if i'm reading a
book
off away from the computer
uh i simply don't look words up in a
dictionary because my experience has
shown me that i forget them it's very
frustrating it's very time consuming it
just destroys the pleasure of reading so
if i if i don't have enough vocabulary
to read the book
in other words to make sense of it even
allow even allowing for words that i
don't understand if i can't do that i
don't read away from the computer so i'm
reading on the computer so
in a way if you listen first
i was at the very beginning you kind of
have to read first or you don't have a
clue but it almost doesn't matter
sometimes i read first to get a bit of
rhythm a bit of momentum and i build up
curiosity curiosity is so important once
you're curious now you heard all the
sound you don't know what it means so
now i'm curious so i want to get in
there and find out what it means
so so i tend to so in that case you
listen first and then you read
uh but i have also in many cases read
first and obviously when i read i'm
looking up every word i look up every
word even words that i
kind of think i know i look them up
and i save them as links unless i'm
really sure that i know them that i
won't save them as link because there's
no harm in saving them as links there's
also no harm in not saving them
and having them count is known because
if you see them again and don't know
what they mean then you save them again
and the
statistics adjust
so
insofar as skimming the first sentence
first i don't do that what i often do
and i will show you that uh sometime is
i'll go through and i'll just go from
blue word to blue word
and so convert them all to yellow and
then i read again looking up the yellow
words because i just find it
psychologically pleasing to see my page
at link get lighter and lighter more
yellow more white
and and then i go through and i again
check the yellow words
so um or should i read and listen first
and then like that no no i i look them
up as i as i go
and then i go away and i listen and i
don't understand and then i read again
but then eventually as you get better of
course you don't have to repeat so often
because
there's only a few words that you missed
you look them up you may forget them
again but you have enough of a sense in
order to
uh make your way through the text
okay do you write out anything by hand
no i don't uh however
if i were
uh
you know studying in a classroom i would
when i was learning chinese
and i had to write an exam at the end i
wrote so i think writing
is very important but i am sort of a
dilettante
but if i were in a classroom i would
write i think writing is very very good
but i can't i i lived in japan for nine
years did business in japanese i can
type in japanese i can't write my hand
in japanese i never write behind in
japanese i don't write by hand in
in russian not to mention greek i have
no intention of writing by hand in
arabic or farsi
but that's
me where i am if i were in a formal
learning environment i would probably
write
uh
okay have you ever been in arabia
why you want to learn the arabic
language okay i have only i have been to
two arabic countries i've been to jordan
briefly
when my wife and i visited we visited
crete israel and then we went into
jordan and went to petra it was a
wonderful experience at that time i
didn't speak any
arabic um
i can tie that into the next question
about revisiting hebrew
uh before going to israel i spent a few
weeks or maybe a month trying to learn
some hebrew
um i wasn't didn't get enough to be able
to use it
i spoke mostly english french and
russian in israel
uh
and but then when i went into jordan i
enjoyed it and i thought to myself
you know there's three four hundred
million people who speak arabic and
there's probably ten or so million who
speak hebrew therefore i would rather
learn arabic however i would like to
revisit hebrew
and getting back to the reasons for
learning arabic
the reasons for learning arabic it's a
very important language world language
it's a major world culture if we look at
history arabic farsi and also hebrew and
greek have had major impacts on world
history so i enjoy learning languages
for
cultural reasons because i'm interested
in history and so that was my reason for
learning arabic and of course
you know i do want to travel to more
arabic countries i was in morocco
with my wife for five days
and while they don't speak fusha as the
sort of standard uh vernacular there
i was able to speak fus with my taxi
drivers with people in restaurants and
uh it was a very pleasant experience and
i got a very positive reaction from
people even by being able to say a few
words in fusa
so that covers those two did you start
with learning the alphabet first with
iranian to be able to read the content
uh
okay
i said to myself if i'm going to go to
the trouble of learning arabic and
learning the arabic writing system
then i should um
kill two birds with one stone so to
speak and also go after farsi
and so therefore by the when i started
and the other thing was
farsi is easier to read than arabic the
the writing system is more consistent so
by getting into farsi and then kind of
speeding up my reading i feel this has
also helped me in reading arabic
uh okay next question i have
the feeling that i have to be advanced
my current target language in order to
start learning a new one what would you
say that
i cannot reach advanced levels so i
can't start a new one
you know it depends what your goals are
i learned romanian because i was going
to be in romania for a week i learned
greek in order to be able to say some
things when we were visiting crete
i can always go back to them
i had a specific
goal and reason for learning them i have
a sense of those languages
uh i have a base
where i can go back to them
but
then i was motivated to learn arabic
i was briefly motivated to learn hebrew
and then decided to move on to arabic
i haven't lost what i've done in hebrew
i can always go back to it so
to me it's a matter of what you want to
do
and whatever you put into a language
it's not lost and if all of a sudden the
motivation is stronger to learn another
language then
why not do that unless you have a
professional or some other reason for
wanting to achieve an even higher level
in in the first language
here i have about 7000 known words on
link and about 20 000 links to foreign
spanish i have done very little
concerning grammar but i think i need it
now do you have thoughts on proceeding
okay
uh
grammar
we
do need occasionally to refer to grammar
the best time to refer to grammar in my
opinion is when you are genuinely
curious about how certain things work so
once you have 7000 known words you have
been exposed to enough of the language
so that
you know so that
you know the grammar explanations make
sense
which is important i'm going to
stop the screen sharing here
so that the grammar explanations make
sense
and that's why
while you're studying now we have at
link for example when you uh save a word
there is the opportunity to tag it for a
certain grammar feature uh
very often there are
conjugating dictionaries for example so
i find it very useful when i look up a
verb and i go to context reverso or one
of these conjugating dictionaries
conjugator
and i look up and i quickly review the
conjugations not with the intention
of being able or the expectation of uh
being able to remember anything but it's
just another form of exposure to the
language and i find this useful and so
that
you know the whole business of learning
a language is a bit like a bit of a
jigsaw puzzle
and uh the picture gradually becomes
clearer gradually it becomes clearer as
we acquire more words as we're more used
to reading in the language as we're
we're more used to sort of seeing
meaning immediately without having to go
through our own language uh certain
structures
seem natural to us and so we're getting
a sense naturally of the grammar but
also looking up the grammar explanation
reviewing the conjugation tables the
declension tables some explanations it's
all part of making the picture clearer
so i definitely
my beef with grammar instruction is that
they started from the beginning when you
have no exposure to the language and and
the assumption is that some kind of
explanation and a few drills are going
to enable you to function correctly in
the language i don't believe that's the
case i believe that we learn much more
naturally the way
you know from a evolutionary perspective
we just pick things up the brain
responds to the experience with the
language and then the explanations can
help they're part of the picture and
especially if we are curious we want to
know it's not an explanation that's ex
is sort of imposed on us but it's
something that we want to understand
better and in that way it's going to
stick with us
i have close to ten thousand words in
french where am i on a hockey stick all
right of course i have this vision of
the upside down hockey stick where at an
early stage we're listening repeatedly
we're we're rereading we're perhaps
reviewing more words and phrases trying
to get a handle on the language that's
the steep
uh
sort of initial climb and then we're on
that long long road of acquiring more
and more words listening to more and
more hopefully interesting content it
might be movies that you find on youtube
and you can import into link for example
so at ten thousand words in french
i think you are at an early stage on
that hockey stick you're past the
initial steep climb and you might be one
third of the way along
uh because
the words that you now have to acquire
are the less frequent words
less frequent but very important in a
particular context
and um
because they're less frequent you don't
come across them as often and so they're
more difficult to to acquire
and so therefore it's a long long road
but it's got to be an enjoyable road so
if you're listening to stuff that you
like you know it could be
you know movies it could be song it
could be literature it could be history
it could be something that relates to
your work
you're now at the stage where you're not
so deliberately learning the language
but you're actually enjoying the
language and in that way gradually
acquiring it but at ten thousand words
uh i would think you're about a third of
the way along
mind you it's an endless hockey stick
all right that you you cannot learn you
is the native speaker of that language
that has lived in that language since
they were a child they're gonna always
have more
vocabulary even passive vocabulary that
then you have or not always but in most
cases so it's a long road but
if you enjoy it it doesn't matter you're
having fun
so do you have dreams
or another
i don't get that question uh other
languages do appear in my dreams
to the extent that i'm aware of the
language that i'm dreaming in
i know that sometimes i dream that i'm
traveling in japan or something so i'm
speaking japanese or french or whatever
i guess it's mostly in english
all right
i guess that's it we ran over i
apologize for the technical glitch at
the beginning
um
i'm going to work this out and if i can
get the
the ipad to work with my computer and to
have
our google hangouts on then i will show
you how i work on the ipad because
actually i do more of my linking
activity on the ipad than on the
computer because it's just so much more
convenient
to me now other people prefer to do it
on the computer
all right then thank you for listening
bye for now